من عمان ينضم الينا اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء
اهلا وسهلا بك هل تلحظ اي تغيير في طبيعه
المعارك والاسلحه المستخدمه فيها
والتكتيكات التي تتبع
لا يعني تقريبا هي اصبحت صوره مكرره منذ
اليوم الاول حتى دخلت في اليوم السادس
القتال يتركز بصوره رئيسيه في الخرطوم ما
يطلق عليها مدينه الخرطوم في ثلاثه نقاط
رئيسيه المطار القياده
والقصر الجمهوري هناك اشتباكات تدور في
سواء الخرطوم بحري او ام درمان وهذه تتعلق
بالتطورات والتغيرات على الارض منذ الصباح
الحديث يتركز في معظم مواقع الاخبار ومعظم
المحطات عن القتال في جنوب غرب اودرمان
ويعزل بعض بانه
وتم الاعلان عن اسقاط طائرتين
عموديتين
ومعظم الاخبار التي تتحدث تقول ان الاسباب
تعود الى استخدام قوات لدعم السريع لتعزيز
مواقعها اذا دعني اقول الاطار العام
للقتال لا يزال هو في اليوم الاول اليوم
الثاني اليوم الثالث قوات ولم يتم الحسم
هل تعني المعلومه من داخل السودان ام من
الخارج نعم نعم نعم كلا الجانبين يحاول ان
هناك نقطه اساسيه لابد من الوقوف امامها
وهي
مدينه الخرطوم باركانها الثلاثيه مركز
الثقل الاستراتيجي من يسيطر عليها ويكسب
المعركه بها يستطيع القول انه سيطر على
النقاط الحاسمه الاساسيه التي تمثل البعد
السياسي والبعد الامني والبعد العسكري
وبعد التواصل مع الخارج وبالتالي كلاهما
حريص على ان يكسب هذه المعركه وكلاهما
يستخدم قوات من الولايات
المجاوره من داخل السودان الجيش السوداني
استخدم
من الغضارف من
ولايه وادي النيل الان حميدت يستقبل
يستخدم قوات من الولايات الاخرى ولكنه
تمركز
للقوات الى الخرطوم ولكن بالنسبه للقوات
الدعم السريع الا يملك الجيش ما يكفي في
سلاح الجو للاستهداف التعزيزات التي قد
تكون قادمه من خارج العاصمه
يا سيدي حتى لو كان يكفل هو اولا يمتلك
حوالي 82 طائره مقاتله سواء دعم ارضي او
او هجوم وهذه الطائرات دمرت قسم منها عرضت
صور لا نعرف الاعداد كم بقي ما هي درجه
الصلاحيه اذا نحن نتحدث عن لغه ارقام
خلفيه ضبابيه يعني لا نستطيع يعني لا
يستطيع اي شخص الا قائد سلاح الجو
السوداني اذا لديه المعلومه ان يقول لديه
على سبيل المثال 60 طائره جاهزه للاستخدام
هذا الامر عندما تحدث عن السودان مليون
و800 الف كيلو متر مربع لا يمكن لهذا
العدد من الطائرات ان يسيطر بصوره كامله
لا يمكن له ان يغطي الاجواء بصوره كامله
على مستوى اذا ذهبنا الى مناطق اخرى
والقدرات الامريكيه في منطقه التنف الحدود
السوريه الاردنيه العراقيه منطقه الخمسه
وخمسين يتم اختراقها بطائرات مسيره او
بدوريات ارضيه وهي تحت السيطره الامريكيه
هنا انا لا ابرر ولكن اقول يستحيل على
الجيش السوداني ان يسيطر وعلى الاجواء
لمتابع كل حركه لماذا تعتقد انه لم يتمكن
اي من الطرفين من حسم المعركه المعركه او
ابعاد الطرف الاخر من النقاط الاساسيه
التي تحدثنا عنها القصر الجمهوري القياده
العامه والمطر
اولا لجمله اسباب اهمها عدم عدم وجود او
توفر القدره القدره العسكريه
الحقيقيه التي تمكن من حجم المعركه كيف
للقصر الجمهوري ان تبقى عناصر الدعم
السريع بداخله لمده خمسه ايام كامله ولا
يمكن اخراجهم كيف يتم تطويق مبنى القياده
العامه لمده خمسه ايام ولا يفك الحصار
عنها كيف يمكن
تبادل السيطره على مطار مروي
مرتين لكل جانب اذا عدم توفر القدرات
العسكريه اولا ولا اود ان اتهم هناك ضعف
في اداره المعركه هناك ضعف في تحديد
الاولويات الاهداف التي يجب التعامل معها
اذا اردت ان تكسب حربا معينه عليك ان تضع
تقدير موقف دقيق يحدد الاهداف واهميه
الاهداف وخطوب من حيث الخطوره ومن حيث
الفاعليه اذا حددت اهدافك يتم تحديد
المرحله الاولى لو تم اعداد تقدير موقف
صحيح من قبل الجيش السوداني لتوصل في
قراءه عاجله ان عليه ان يؤمن اربعه اشياء
لا مجال للتجاهل اي منها عليه ان يؤمن
القياده العامه ان يؤمن
القصر الجمهوري ان يؤمن المطار ان يؤمنوا
الجسور لو استبق الاحداث وامن هذه المناطق
الاربعه لا يمكن ان يجري ما جرى في مدينه
السودان كذلك الجانب المقابل لو كان لديه
تخطيط استراتيجي كان عليه ان يفكر في
السيطره عليها ومنذ اللحظه الاولى يتمكن
منها اذا دعني اقول لا الامكانيات لا تسمع
ولا القدرات التخطيطيه واداره المعركه
ترقى الى مستوى ايضاح الصوره على
المستوبين العمليات والاستراتيجي مما يمكن
القائد من الحاسب السريع اللواء فاز
دويريه الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجي شكرا
جزيلا لك